I don't care how many tabs you have open
I care what the tabs are if they're 42
porn tabs you have a problem if they're
42 really interesting Tabs go for it go
to 50. I'm Malcolm Global as an author
and journalist I do a lot of research so
today I'm here to answer your questions
from Twitter this is research support
[Music]
question number one at Super cyanation
supersization how reliable is Wikipedia
really
well
it's not bad
I mean it's really interesting to
compare Wikipedia entries to their
counterpart in an encyclopedia
so Encyclopedia Britannica for example
they would go and find an expert in a
field and have that expert write the
entry with Wikipedia you get a mixture
of people who are real experts and
people who just want to participate so
when I look on my Wikipedia page for
example there's a lot of a lot of weird
stuff on that page that isn't terribly
true on the other hand if you want to
very quickly figure out what I've
written and the things I'm interested in
my Wikipedia PD page is pretty good
Wikipedia is really good if you lower
your expectations it is a gateway to
research so use Wikipedia to start your
search and use it for clues about where
to go next add a rune grape it asks how
are libraries still going who's going to
a library in 2022
yours truly goes to libraries that's
because lots of things are only in a
library the the amount of stuff that you
can get on the internet is a tiny
fraction of the sum total of knowledge
in the world tons of books aren't online
the person who asks is going to diss
them but I'm about to diss them they're
clearly uninterested in anything that
happened before I don't know the year
2000 or 2010 which by the way if you're
trying to be a smart person in the world
is a crazy way to live your life what
the internet is really good at is
directed search libraries are great for
serendipitous search and I'm reading a
book and I'm that's next to it on the
shelf or 10 books down on the Shelf it
catches my eye I pick it out I flip
through the index I see something that's
really useful that's Library search
serendipitous search is how you come up
with new ideas the other great thing
about libraries is librarians
a library has an actual
set of experts who are there to help you
out whereas you know who's helping you
when you're messing around on Google at
2AM at Nelly 101 asks is it me or did
McDonald's fries taste better as kids
Nelly it's not you they absolutely did
we did a podcast episode on this in
revisionist history all about how
McDonald's changed the formula the
recipe for their fries in the 1980s in
response to this totally bogus bit of
research that suggested that the cooking
oil they were using was somewhat bad for
your heart
as it turns out it's not bad for your
heart but they moved away from they used
to use a kind of uh beef Talent it was
beef fat and they moved to vegetable oil
and actually the research suggests that
vegetable oil is worse for you not only
do fries taste worse cooked in vegetable
oil than the old way but the fry itself
is now probably worse for your heart
than the old fry was at John all press
52 says is the Ten Thousand hour rule
real or make believe well now he's
referring to uh an idea I wrote about in
my book outliers in looking at research
in cognitively complex Fields what we
find overwhelmingly is that people need
about ten thousand hours of practice
before they become experts ten thousand
hours is you know it's roughly 10 years
so it takes 10 years to be good at
something it's basically what the rule
says if the thing is hard chess players
it's very hard to find someone who can
reach the level of of uh Grand Master
who hasn't been playing chess for 10
years very hard to find someone who can
be an elite point guard in the NBA who
hasn't been playing point guard for 10
years I mean this is famously a problem
in in the NBA in evaluating
um rookies you draft someone to play
point guard and you say oh they're
they're a disappointment and the reason
is it's too early because that's the
most demanding position on the court in
basketball it's not make believe this is
a real Rule and the research suggests
that and a good average for how long you
need to spend on that is about ten
thousand hours
at a kid named Sig asks the word
research has become so watered down like
do you really think a five second Google
search the topic or Point you're trying
to make and clicking the first three
results that pop up is research couldn't
agree with you more when you're looking
for a definitive factual answer Google's
really good but when you get into more
complicated questions you need to do a
little more research I think it's useful
to be a little bit skeptical about the
information you get on the internet and
I think the reason we don't do that all
the time is that being skeptical is
exhausting checking is also slightly
problematic because the question is well
how do you check it the thing you're
using to check the original fact is
itself
a trustworthy Source writing to riches
asks what is the biggest predictor of
success if you only choose one factor
social skills IQ Etc biggest predictor
of success is probably having a rich
parent I tried to answer this question
in my book outliers and my answer was
it's a it's it's impossible to boil it
down to one thing what we do now is that
your IQ is probably a smaller is a
smaller role than you think and your own
efforts play a smaller role than you
think it's probably more to do with luck
and good fortune and having people
around you help you those are probably
the things that make the biggest
difference
at Ross Showalter asks how do
non-fiction writers know when to stop
working on a piece you never really know
you know when to stop when they take it
away from you I actually think that's
the wrong question
the right question is most people I
think work too little on the pieces all
the serious writers I know do way way
way way way way more
drafts and work much longer on their
writing than other people if you think
you should stop working
on it you probably need to do another
draft
at John picciuto asks why do smart
people do dumb things my podcast came up
with
a hypothesis at least in the case of
Will Chamberlain and many of his friends
he didn't shoot free throws underhanded
he did for one season and in that one
season he was suddenly a fantastic
free-throw shooter and then he went back
to shooting free throws the old way
reverted to being a terrible free-throw
shooter and by the way it was the only
flaw in Wilt Chamberlain's game had he
been able to shoot free throws well he
would have been hands down the greatest
basketball player of all time and Wilt
said he didn't want to look like an
idiot people would rather
not look like an idiot then become the
greatest basketball player
of all time why do smart people uh do
dumb things because they don't want to
look like an idiot at Oxley teaches ing
asks what is bad science exactly oh man
there's many different definitions of
bad science but science committed by
people who think they know the answer
before they start is there's a guy named
John Lott who writes about
guns and crime and he's the only person
who claims that the more guns you have
the less crime you have but then you
realize that John lot is like
ideologically committed to the Second
Amendment to gun rights and you really
have to ask yourself is his research
honest the gold standard for figuring
out whether something's good or bad is
can it be replicated so if I do a study
that says the experience of New York
City over the last 25 years and I draw
the conclusion that more guns equals
less crime can someone else take a look
at that same database and reach the same
conclusion at honestly atheists how do
you attempt to overcome confirmation
bias
information bias is it's one of the
biggest mistakes that people make when
it comes to interpreting data a good
example would be you've decided that
getting a coveted vaccine will
cause all kinds of illness well every
time you hear a story about somebody who
had a bad side effect from getting their
coveted shot you say see I told you this
thing's crazy it's killing us now what
you're neglecting is that
99.99999999 of people who get a coveted
shot are not only totally fine and
healthy but actually prevent themselves
from getting all kinds of diseases
that's confirmation bias you selectively
find information in the world to support
your erroneous conclusion how prevalent
is that example how many times does it
occur you can't just rely on your own uh
personal anecdotal experience Anna
pinata ass how do you get yourself
excited about writing your research
paper when you've lost interest if you
dislike something or getting bored with
something you probably haven't done
enough work on it in other words boredom
is a intermediate stage it's a kind of
plateau you get on after you've scraped
the surface
but you've got to go beyond that and
everything
virtually everything is interesting if
you dig
deep and hard enough so my advice would
be to keep going in that situation
at is a [ __ ] asks why is country music
so sad I'm crying Iza
funny you should ask I did a podcast
episode on this very question it was
called the king of Tears in that episode
king of Tears a reference to a really
brilliant bit of research that was about
the specificity of song lyrics
so it looked at all kinds of popular
song lyrics from you know rock music
folk music country music and the
question is how complex were the nurse
make a specificity scale rock music's on
the far end of the non-specific end of
the scale and country music's on the far
specific end of the scale the argument
in King of Tears was that what moves us
emotionally is specificity and
complexity Olivier Talbot 27 asks how
did writers research before the internet
than all kinds of emojis of people
before the internet we went to libraries
and we call people up on the phone who
knew things and asked them questions
both strategies I would wholeheartedly
endorse for anyone who's interested in
learning about the world in a profound
way at antithesis 1 asks what is an
intelligence failure
which is often cited as the cause of
unwanted events well the classic
intelligence failure would be 911. there
was a famous study conducted by the
senate in the aftermath of 9 11 which
said look all the clues were there why
didn't we why didn't we pick up on them
and prevent 9 11. this is intelligence
failure let's say we could find 10
pieces of intelligence that pointed
directly to what Al Qaeda was planning
on 9 11. they're buried in a mountain of
a million different data points it's not
an easy matter to find the ten that
matter out of a mountain of a million I
would say be suspicious of people who
use the term intelligence failure after
the fact
at another Panacea asks has any
psychologist been worse for the world
than Philip zimbardo fake the Stanford
Prison Experiment and help create the
justifications for broken windows
policing We'll add another Panacea could
not disagree with you more zimbardo
didn't fake the Stanford Prison
Experiment this is the famous experiment
where zimbardo gathered together a bunch
of volunteers and said to one group of
them your prison guards to another group
said your prisoners and he ran a
simulation over the course of I think
several days what he discovers is that
the prison guards take it very seriously
and end up doing things that they would
never ordinarily do and he was trying to
understand why ordinary Germans would
have been capable of committing such
terrible offenses during the second
world war this different prison
experiment is controversial because it's
complicated did zimbardo overstate his
case did he draw conclusions he
shouldn't have it's not faked it's just
difficult second part of your question
broken windows policing which was an
idea that was uh first put forward by a
very brilliant researcher called George
Kelling that idea says that if you
tolerate small acts of disorder large
acts of disorder will follow so it's why
in the subway in New York they realize
the first step in cleaning up the subway
was in cracking down on people who jump
the turnstiles you cracked in on the
small act and what that does is it sends
a signal to everybody else now you can
take it to extremes and there's
departments that did take it to extremes
but the the idea itself is something
that has been I think verified on many
occasions in research at doomed hippo
asks I have a research question looking
into paranormal stuff and having a hard
time I'm mostly seeing blogs parroting
the same people Legends say and not
getting first-hand reports of hauntings
how do I get to the actual primary
sources of these stories
So my aunt would always say that the
living room in her house in Jamaica was
haunted can I verify it did I take a
picture did I write it up in a
scientific journal no it's the story We
Tell in our family I suspect that's
where stories about ghosts are found
their stories told from one person to
another they're not written up in the
literature and searchable on Google
the problem you have uh uh at doomed
hippo is that you're in a pretty kind of
squishy area it's not like there are a
ton of scientists at reputable
universities who are doing
case-controlled studies on paranormal
sightings so the minute you start moving
away from the mainstream you are going
to be Reliant overwhelmingly on
anecdotes doing first-hand research
yourself
probably the best approach finding
people who have seen ghosts and bring a
tape recorder and putting in front of
them and asking them about their
experience
shoot me an email I'll tell you my ghost
story the question is from Natalie is
blue and she asks why do most wealthy
people play golf this is a reference to
our revisionist history episode which
was called a good walk spoiled in the
course of which I talk about a really
fascinating study it's called a natural
experiment when you can find data that's
just out in the world serious golfers
register their rounds of golf on the U.S
whatever the U.S Golf Association
services and so this guy this young
brilliant Economist he had a database
that allowed him to predict exactly how
much golf
CEOs of companies played there was a
correlation between how well your
company was doing and how much golf you
played the more golf you played the
worse your company was doing to answer
your question Natalie why do most
wealthy people play golf well probably
because it takes a lot of money to play
golf probably because they have a lot of
time in their hands but also because
they're more concerned about their
leisure time than running the companies
that they're supposed to run at everyone
cares asks trying to figure out if it's
normal that I have 42 tabs open at once
on my laptop
because I'm totally going to read
research looking to this soon how many
tabs do you have open usually
I don't know
10 to 15. I actually aggressively close
and open just because it stresses me out
I know someone who thinks that a great
interview question
for somebody is have the subject of the
the interviewee take out their laptop
and show you how many tabs they have
open on their browser and by looking at
the things they're interested in you can
get a really good sense of what they're
like so I guess I would say if they're
42 really interesting tabs about stuff
that pops into your head Go For It Go to
50. at Sprucey 1969 asks is there a word
that describes the action of digging out
yet more sources to research rather than
actually writing other than
procrastination what you've described is
are going off on getting getting lost in
tangents which I don't know if that's a
bad thing
if you're enjoying yourself why not
so those are all the questions for today
I thought there were some great
questions a lot of you clearly have been
reading some of my books and listening
to some of revisions history podcasts
those of you who haven't have your work
cut out for you uh thanks for watching
research support
[Music]